well this is it everyone after the long
wait the turkey convention is finally
here was it worth the wait did it live
up to our expectations did they finally
get the color of the suit right well if
I answered these questions in the first
paragraph this video wouldn't be that
long now would it
it's honestly been a bumpy road getting
here and I've been a little afraid to
write this review because I know people
have been waiting for it for so long I
have a lot to live up to I guess no
pressure right
but after stressing myself out like
crazy about it I finally figured out
what I want to do I'm just gonna say how
I feel and that should be good enough
let's hop right in and since there's no
fall damage that shouldn't be a problem
I've made a lot of jokes about people
over hyping this game in the last two
years and a lot of them misconstrue that
for me saying the game will suck I hear
a lot of just because you're not excited
doesn't mean you have to mock everyone
who is which is the finest damn straw
man argument this side of the
Mississippi no I'm not making fun of
people who are excited because I was
excited too
I took potshots at people who are being
unreasonable and having expectations
this game could never live up to when
people are on ironically pushing for it
to be game of the year 2018 two months
before it even releases you know there's
a problem however I think it lived up to
my expectations which were it'll
probably just be like the amazing
spider-man games but more polished and
with a respectable budget and in that
regard I wasn't let down at all well
unfortunately this game is not the
second coming of Christ that has ended
all strife and I should fourth a
prosperous Golden Age of man it's still
pretty good
is it definitive Spider Man game good
well I guess that's the question we're
here to answer aren't we let's take a
look at this thing piece by piece and
see how it holds up oh there's a
standalone and as an addition to a long
lineage of dead uncle simulators be
warned that there's so much to cover and
talk about with this game that I'll
probably be listing it out by sections
instead of writing clever transitions if
you think you could do better write your
own 14 page review maybe it's the game
we've been looking for that'll finally
make you feel like a poor person would
weigh too much guilt in high
intelligence that he wasted a dead-end
job with several failed relationships
and extreme depression they mask
gameplay okay so there's a lot to sort
through here but right off the bat I'm
very happy with the combat it feels like
insomniac actually did listen up and
take notes from the previous videos I
think the perfect Spider Man fight
mechanic should be like a cross between
Ultimates visceral and acrobatic melee
moveset spider-man to spider sense dodge
and web of shadows web strikes the
punches feel powerful and painful you
can dodge an enemy's attacks and fluid
motions and you can take the fight to
the skies and combine movement with the
attacks if I were a betting man I'd say
it was just a case of parallel thinking
in a lot of ways because why on earth
would they take the advice of a schmuck
like me have you seen how I dress as I
requested the combat feels like it has a
lot of weight and impact with
spider-man's punches carrying a lot of
strength he's not shooting lasers out of
his hands like in the old days but it
feels very visceral and powerful plus
you can do all kinds of neat stuff like
swing kick from friend or foe bouncing
off walls like ultimate in a strong
uppercut like in spider-man 2 it's not
just mashing two buttons this combat is
fun and engaging and it takes a while a
fully master I also appreciate that
instead of using a counter button like
in the Arkham games they just use a
spider sense dodge mechanic to hop out
of the way when it looks like you're
about to get splattered like
Charlemagne's head sorry Charlie
remember that time Spiderman
accidentally killed that lady why don't
we talk about that anymore anywho
there's plenty of spider-man slaughter
to be had in this game to check out all
this nice non-lethal friendly
neighborhood street justice okay
nothing like a bit of the old
ultraviolence the only thing I think
they could have improved on combat is
the aerial battles there are a couple of
flying enemies in the game and taking
them on feels a little clunky granted
the sky combat works but it won't top
the web strike from web of shadows God
was that a cool mechanic you could fight
pretty much any enemy in that game
without ever having to touch the ground
throw that in the sequel please I mean
there's something kind of like the web
strike here but it's just it's not it
sucks
he just whacks them and goes back to
standing on the ground like a punk oh I
guess the air throws in web yank and
whatnot are okay something I think they
finally nailed was what to do with
spider-man's damn webbing every game has
tackled it and couldn't quite figure out
how to fully utilize it in comments
since he can do so many things with it
some games the web's were just a stream
to tie guys up sometimes it was wet
pellets to stun enemies sometimes it was
to swing them around and throw them off
buildings come on you know you did it
that game solves the conundrum with a
simple solution just to have a weapon
wheel to cycle through them plus a few
other neat gadgets which you're pretty
hit or miss impact webbing is awesome
you can send criminals flying with it
the seismic blast thing is kind of lame
because only knocks them back a little
bit and it's kind of redundant come on
guys we already tried that stick an
amazing spider-man 2 it's not really a
great idea I mean it kind of works if
you drop a web bomb first and then just
shove ever on at a wall I guess - lame
gadgets used in succession makes for
something cool so I'll give them a pass
the antigravity bomb thing feels kind of
dumb I can't really picture spider-man
using something like that pass but not
like like a pass like the other things
god I mean like like pass them up and
whatever okay now this one I like this
spider drone may not seem like much but
when you fully upgraded its super
overpowered just unleash your swarm of
robots and by the time you finish
punching one guy the other twelve
standing behind them are already on the
ground
sobbing damn this thing's badass I think
I'll name him charlie
one of the gameplay elements I felt took
a step down from the predecessors with
stealth combat it's just so unbelievably
easy especially considering the amount
of gadgets you can use it's like the
amazing spider-man games is stealth
except well actually yes just like that
but even easier just impact webbing
every guy near a wall or ledge drop some
tripmines around corners let the Charlie
swarm over take the thugs like a plague
of fashionable mechanical locusts and of
course you can just web everyone up to
these posts and support beams while
they're oblivious friends aren't looking
move my nest of corpses I shall feed
upon them with my acidic things for I am
The Bone Collector my Charlie's will
consume this pitiful earth you know what
I think you can do pretty much every
stealth segments in a couple seconds
flat if you're quick enough the enemy AI
just doesn't really match up to
something like Arkham they're pretty
clueless and easy to pick off after a
while stealth even starts to get a
little repetitive because of this maybe
some extra animations for the stealth
takedowns wouldn't hurt what happened to
webbing guys well on the ceiling or
walls maybe they could have done with
more event crawling and give you places
to hide - it just feels like insomnia
max just threw their hands in the air
and said whatever to this section the
gameplay my god Otto this invention is
amazing we could make a mint with this
thing I'll start working on the pitch
for the Board of Directors right away
what's even worse is the stealth
sections where you aren't even
spider-man long gone are the days where
the alternate playable character in your
spider-man campaign is someone cool like
venom now you got a walk around as
people man and dunce cap the dynamic
racially diverse duo who do nothing [ __ ]
I ruined my alliteration well anyway you
sometimes plays these two knuckleheads
and these sections feel really stiff and
clunky it kills the pacing super hard
like you just got done with an uncharted
style explosive action set piece and
then they ground you as MJ who dies if
any enemy so much as looks at her
general direction what was the idea
behind that having you play as Marvel's
answer to Superman one second and the
next you be this paper-mache pushover as
these sections go on they introduce
other mechanics for tricking guards into
looking away or moving around the area a
bit more but that hardly makes it more
engaging then on the last section is MJ
you're finally allowed to do a stealth
takedown which well then that makes the
mission trivial I get what they were
doing with these sections but they feel
just like ill placed and poorly timed
with the game's campaign makes you wish
they put as much focus into playing as
these characters a Spidey what if MJ had
a Taser or a can of mace for the whole
game
or maybe miles could use some other
gadgets to knock out enemies he'll give
me a mechanic to just knock furniture
over on top of people anything would
have been better than nothing
you also have sections of just walking
around indoors as Peter which isn't
anything new but like some people were
pushing for playing as Peter in the open
world no boring that would be it would
be this it's just this that's what you
would get annoyed
oh you well that's embarrassing what'd
they think no one was gonna look up
there while the stealth sequences may
lack a lot of thought and polish the
open-world explanation is the polar
opposite the city looks gorgeous and
feels livelier than ever before it
finally feels like New York has the
correct amount of people and cars the
city feels dense layered and crowded but
never to the point of feeling
claustrophobic you still have plenty of
room for web-swinging and constant
menacing in fact insomniac apparently
made the streets wider in the building's
taller to accommodate for the spider
themed Constabulary to roam around and
they also forgot to include Washington
Heights again zero out of ten not
accurate they didn't have that crack on
the street by Fifth Avenue that I saw in
the background of a picture once in 2008
swinging around in the city is also
extremely relaxing and fun look at all
these spider-man II poses he does in the
game's animations look so fancy the
swinging is just the right speed he has
the right amount of physics applied to
it and it never gets old granted
sometimes you get some cloud swinging
but I think that's okay as long as it's
not super noticeable it's one thing to
have the webs attached like three feet
to the left of the building it's another
to have it attached like 40 or just
attached to no buildings at all
speaking of webs not attaching to things
they'll never patch this cutscene Plus
unlike most open-world games they
actually give you a decent amount of
things to do in the city it's not like
that stupid operation flashpoint Dragon
Rising where you can walk from one end
of the game's map to the other in 24
hours but it's all just trees and rocks
no one is impressed by the size of your
game map if there's nothing to do in it
Todd
but anyway the side missions are
plentiful and you'll have a lot of
variation that keeps you going after
them be it fighting some lower level
villains from the comics getting some
really well-written dialogue cutscenes
or just feeling like you're doing
something spider-man would do a lot of
these side missions have their own
stories and characters that remind me of
those one-off spider-man issues from
back in the old days of comics like this
one where some bird watcher calls Spidey
down for help and tells him that
something fishy's going on in Central
Park and then he has a lot of
interesting back and for
with her across the mission is she
helped you take down the bad guys this
feels just like an 80s filler issue and
those are some of my favorite Spidey
stories you really get a sense that he's
a man of the people
and a big-time superhero because while
he's fighting threats that want to
destroy the city and take over the world
he also stops to the little stuff no
threat is too big or small Spidey is one
of the few heroes who would actually
stop and go help out a guy who was
inspired by him to fight crime in his
costume
Ironman wouldn't help this dude he'd be
dead the side missions are also charming
well written well paced and fun that
they distract you from playing the main
story in fact I was procrastinating the
final boss for ages because I was having
so much fun bombing around as a
street-level hero with all these more
down-to-earth troubles but when you do
take on these bigger threats that's when
he feels like the type of guy who could
beat up the entire x-men all at once
remember that they had to erase his
memory of why he was beating them up so
that they could get him to stop people
downplay it a lot but spider-man is kind
of overpowered and I think this game
does a great job of accurately
representing his strengths
finally a spider-man who knows how to
stop a moving vehicle more than once in
a row I could call it the bomb squad
bombs I are triggers between bottles
the bomb triggers bombs underthings time
to find those other bombs beyond the
story of the side missions the game also
puts in plenty of reasons to explore the
city and do the street crimes instead of
some dumbass arbitrary point system
that's hard to keep track of you just
get one token per crime and maybe some
extra ones if you stop the crime in a
specific way what do you get with these
tokens the usual upgrades gadgets and
who those mad geniuses finally figured
out how to give incentive to stop Street
crimes they've weaponized our obsession
with alternate suits all they gotta do
is dangle a fancy new costume in front
of us and we actually want to stop thugs
for the first time and well never look
at all these kick-ass alternate costumes
so many slight variations of the classic
suit I can't even choose should I wear
torn classic suit additional black lions
classic suit cel-shaded classic suit
shiny classic suit or classic classic
suit hey wait a minute
otherwise the rest of the suits are
pretty cool whatevs I think they just
wanted to make a list of ones we haven't
really seen before because all the
obvious ones seem to be absent
ironically in spite of defending this
design and my videos leading up to the
game when given the choice I never used
it during my first playthrough I think I
just associate the image of it with all
the rude comments from people with it in
their profile pics so anyway traversal
the open world the unlockables the
combat and the side missions are all
great it really nailed all that stuff
and in spite of my mockeries with their
minor flaws
I love the hell out of almost all of it
however I would be biased if I didn't
list off stuff that I think just sucked
and not like a bunch of fake cop-out
flawed things like oldest games 19 hours
long and it would have been better if it
were 20 but it's still great or
spider-man's suit is a really orange a
shade of red we're talking the real
stuff like how the wall-crawling
mechanic feels like a complete
afterthought and you can't climb around
2 inch tall corners come on how can you
not get over that why are you struggling
get over it stop treating it like Gwen's
death and get over it you SAP God they
have all these wall-crawling sections
that are ripped straight from the PS
games but they only work because you're
going up a completely flat surface I
thought we had this mechanic figured out
guys come on what's with these hacking
meaning games it's the most generic
minigame ever and they take the game's
pacing to a grinding halt like you're
doing all this high octane super power
to action schlock and it just stops you
to play the plumbing game from Bioshock
for Doc Ock why am i rhyming for like
they give you the option to skip these I
guess so
just do that if you want to cut your
playtime in half pro tip for all you MLG
speedrunners out there just cheat I love
this game's action set-pieces because
they're really intricately planned and
well animated but it curd to me that
pretty much all of them were in the
game's marketing and they didn't really
have ones we didn't see before when that
helicopter chase sequence have been way
cooler if we didn't see it a year ago
bro you're not gonna believe this
I just met spider-man you know I think
they won't ever actually cop to naming
Myles his friend because the NED ganky
situation would confuse casual viewers
so nondescript hat-wearing friend you
shall remain sir these race missions are
pre annoying and you can't really get
the gold and then without performing 3.2
million point launches which doesn't
really test your ability to swing at all
they're not fun like an ultimate
spider-man they're just kind of tedious
because they have such high expectations
for completion also kind of like
ultimate spider-man boy taskmaster in
this game sure is Deathstroke these
bosses are really underwhelming and
undercooked I think this game couldn't
quite figure out how to mix the big
explosion II action set pieces with the
battles the bosses are just your pretty
standard pattern punch him dodge throw
something at him punch him sometimes
they don't even have that you just gotta
hit the guy until he goes down Spidey is
known for all kinds of creative
problem-solving with his enemies but
that doesn't really factor in here you
won't really need to exploit any
weaknesses or use some kind of trick to
win you can just brute force it why
couldn't they do something like you
trick electro into shorting out vultures
wings or use the spikes that a vulture
throws as a lightning rod to drain
Electra's powers
why not trick scorpion into melting
rhinos armor to make him weaker or like
anything more engaging than just
punching him also this game selection of
bad guys is pretty samey of all
spider-man's villains they really just
use the guys with power armor just just
normal dudes using technology to be
tough the only one with honest-to-god
superpowers is electro and they even
gave him some power armor why not throw
some variety into the mix with a guy
like lizard or Sandman or maybe Mysterio
and while it's very thematically and
emotionally hard-hitting I still feel
like the final boss of this game is
really forgettable in terms of gameplay
now it's kind of a letdown man you know
what else this game need more of high
speed chase sequences with super
villains I know they're kind of cliche
for this series but when the traversal
mechanics are this good why wouldn't you
want to go chasing after vulture or
electro at 90 miles an hour through the
sky you get a really great sequence like
that with shocker and black cat of
course but the only other chases are
with vehicles and obviously they don't
pose much of a chance of giving you the
slip drug-induced dream sequence and
floating debris cityscape Arkham did it
finding a series of partial handprints
throughout a room to fake out a
handprint scanner
Arkham did it hell they even poached
Lucius Fox this backpack thing makes no
sense because the webs dissolve after an
hour how the hell did he forget Sandman
was trapped in a while in one of these
backpacks that's like the most dangerous
thing ever and he left it on the top of
Avengers Tower plus that's pretty
unethical Peter god I can't imagine how
sandman feels being stuck in there he
doesn't even get to see sunlight he just
stares at the lint and notebook paper
all day for years
Jesus graphics this game is gorgeous one
of the most breathtakingly pretty games
I've played in a long time it really
feels like a next-gen experience and
this is the first game with a photo mode
that I actually want to use I know a big
dividing controversy came about from
people arguing about the suppose
the downgrades from the marketing to the
final product well to that I have to say
can you show me any big Triple A game
that doesn't look better at e3 it's a
lot easier to render the game when it's
three percent of the size of the final
product of course the graphics were
gonna take a hit especially since they
had to compact it down for a machine
that's less powerful than PC it happens
to pretty much every game these days
good and bad does it suck that the
colors and textures aren't as nice sure
but they probably cut back on those
areas to help with stuff like load times
and frame rate this game loads so fast I
can't even read the damn hints that's
impressive
but yes there is a downgrade somewhat
and that's to be expected this game
still looks wonderful regardless stop
freaking out you cultists are planning
on suing the developer over this the
changes in most areas are pretty
negligible and minor and another is it
doesn't look much better or worse just
different on the flip side you
zombie-like apologists are just as bad
with all that no the developer said
there wasn't one so there isn't why on
earth would they say anything otherwise
of course they'd be dishonest about it
it's not their job to be honest it's
their job to make sure people buy their
game you'd have to be pretty naive to
believe they openly admit to their
product being less than advertised
out of the kindness of their hearts you
know I feel a pretty big I told you so
coming on right now because I said parts
of the initial III trailer were scripted
and a bunch of people kept going no I
thought gameplay the developers
confirmed it none of that was a cutscene
well I sure enjoyed that trip to Harry's
coffee shop in the final game didn't you
it's kind of weird how this random inner
demon guy and mr. negative switch places
from the demos to the final game duffle
bag come from who did that was it you
characters well this game has a lot of
characters waddling around doing things
in its story campaign so I thought I'd
give special attention to how well I
think they adapted these fictional
people we all know and love
it's a shame Josh Keaton couldn't do the
voice of Spidey in this game maybe it's
because he couldn't do the motion
captured
Oh what why he was right there what was
the point of that
well anyway Ben Tenn did a really good
job of voicing Sasuke man and he proved
he's a very talented digital actor in
the same way that Troy Baker or Nolan
North did in those other games you know
this game has a lot of references to
daredevil Naughty Dog's should make a
game about him since they're down a
franchise I really like this game's take
on Peter it seems like they had a really
strong grasp on multiple aspects of his
personality he's humble and nerdy but
not to the point of seeming overly quiet
and weird he's sarcastic and funny but
not to the point of sounding like an
overconfident jerk he can get pretty
reasonably angry bitter and angsty about
his struggles in life but without going
overboard or sounding whiny and
ultimately still retaining his
hopefulness he feels a lot of guilt but
not to the point of being a self parody
he's tough effective and not incompetent
but still doesn't feel overpowered and
unbeatable he has a tangible passion and
love for science without sounding like
an obnoxious know-it-all plus he's the
right balance of being badass and a
loser
guy can stop a truck with his bare hands
but he also has to do undignified and
humanizing stuff like digging through
the garbage for his personal belongings
that were thrown out after getting
evicted this is my favorite mission in
the game because this scenario and the
awkward phone calls with the Sanitation
dispatcher feel so much like Peter
Parker this is such a normal and
unspectacular conflict in the middle of
all this other crazy and epic stuff I
guess I just like how well-rounded this
interpretation of Peter is he's got a
lot of complex and varied emotional
states and personality traits that make
him feel right out of the comics I think
most of the cartoons and movies tend to
gravitate only towards a handful of
these traits each leaving their versions
of him feeling kind of incomplete but
this guy is the real deal they did a
good job and I like playing as him in
some of the calm or and more
investigative moments just as much as
the action he ones however MJ is just
Lois Lane now well Lois Lane with red
hair or wait is being an actress not
empowering enough is that it I feel like
every modern take on MJ gives her a
different career
personality because of one really crappy
adaptation of her even though she shot
Green Goblin defeated chameleon by
herself saved Spidey from sticks and
stone people will always see her as the
weak damsel in distress that needed to
be fixed
MD was never a damsel before those
movies that was Gwen's job she mo'fucker
takes her up on a bridge he's gonna get
cab before her damn neck snap goblins
ain't [ __ ] - MJ but whatever I guess her
interactions with Peter still feel
mostly on point she's the one with the
real power in the relationship and they
only end up together because she decided
it that's all good to me so I guess I
can excuse her being rebooted as a
journalist for the billionth time as for
everyone else
miles is fine he's just kind of there I
guess I like that we get to meet his dad
first and Jefferson Davis is really cool
um
Otto is actually more likable than he
has been in a long time and I really
like the decision to reinforce his
established relationship with Peter URI
Watanabe continues to be the
personification of we killed off Jean
dewolff too soon so let's replace her
with an identical character mr. negative
is cool for the first time ever because
he's not being written by slotto block
Davis and everyone else is just fine I
guess they got the most important ones
right hey just a heads up in the middle
of the video so people can't skip it I'm
having a hard time financially right now
and it would mean a lot if you could
consider supporting the channel over on
patreon where we have exclusive videos
and behind the scenes stuff and if you
want a more short-term way to help out
check out our merch okay back to the
video story
well this game's story isn't anything
too revolutionary it's a compilation of
a lot of stories throughout the comics
both new and old and it does a decent
job of building this new universe for
future sequels it also seems to use a
lot of ideas from the amazing spider-man
series oddly enough like Harry being
sick Oscorp trying to remake spider-man
spiders to cure him we kind of resolve
that cliffhanger with Fisk from the last
game we got the fake Twitter feed thing
except this time it's a little more
believable and even blue Elektra was
there
[Music]
hey miles fun fact if you eat that
spider you can turn into a sentient high
of mine of a thousand spiders that can
wear people as a skin suit I know you've
been looking for ways to differentiate
yourself from Peter so you know just
throwing it out there man
we start with Spidey finally taking down
that guy from Full Metal Jacket and
realizing a substantial power vacuum has
been left in the crime world this
invites fellows like mr. pessimism and
the Sinestro Corps to try and take down
the corrupt mayor and industrialist
Norman Osmond who looks suspiciously
like that one guy
Wow ain't that some subtle social
commentary for you but Spidey is a
bleeding-heart hippie liberal who isn't
fine with casual public executions and
works tirelessly to stop Norman Osborn
from getting dropped off a building boys
he kind of feel real stupid about this
one in a few years oh wow a spider-man
game where there's a plague that makes
everyone in New York sick that's crazy
we haven't had that before something
unique to this game is their take on
Otto Octavius who is the main villain
because dance lots name was attached to
this so of course he is however this
game reinvents Otto to be more like a
longtime friend and father figure to
Peter Parker who has a slow fall from
grace due to his hubris and longing to
be cured of his physical ailments the
trash boat cometh and Otto loses his
mind making for both a very sad
climactic battle and an obnoxious amount
of hints about superior spider-man being
in the sequel this all culminates in a
very emotional ending that just sort of
awkwardly cuts to credits you know I
feel like it's always really weird when
they don't end these on a cool swinging
shot exactly why we broke up what MJ no
I would up if it was it you know what
can we not do this right now
please listen I gotta go Peter
nice work mr. superhero MJ is not happy
we've seen another game that balances
Peters normal life in superhero antics
pretty well and another game that gave
us a gauntlet of bad guys to test our
wits it's nothing new but I've noticed
the Internet is taken to saying this
game is the best spider-man movie or
this is the best spider-man story we've
seen in ages but that begs the question
why is everyone hailing this game is the
best adaptation of spider-man since oh
what is it about this version of Pietro
Parkman that beats everything else we've
seen well I think the answer is rather
simple
responsibility at the end of the game he
makes a hard choice and chooses to do
the right thing and more than just
responsibility it's acceptance of
adulthood for context in 2007 we saw a
Peter Parker faced with a similar
situation where he could either embrace
his future or throw it away to save on
May and for whatever a brain-dead reason
Peter suddenly can't deal with loss
anymore and reverts from a married man
with a daughter and a decent job as a
teacher to a jobless manchild who still
lives with his mom and doesn't have a
girlfriend beyond just losing MJ this
was Peter Parker losing his adulthood
and being shoved back into his youth
because it felt safer at home without me
he rejected the concept of being a man
to stay a boy a little longer
even though onme had already lived a
long life and would have probably been
proud of his decision had he moved on
then we have one of the greatest movie
trilogies of all time tank itself with a
shoddy third installment where Peter
becomes an overconfident self-absorbed
jerk even before he got the black suit
only for it to be rebooted with a
franchise Bri ignores a man's dying wish
to make the sacrifice of leaving Glen
out of his life and in selfishly keeping
her causing her death now we have a
third rendition where this franchise
does everything it can to remind you
that he's still young at every turn and
then we get this nice little game where
Peter is just a grown man who just just
lets go Aunt May is the only connection
to his childhood and he leaves her
behind so he can save the city and move
on with his life
because it's the right thing to do
spider-man was never about a kid being a
superhero it was about a kid becoming a
man because he was a superhero
it was about growing up through his
sacrifice in his pain molding him into
being a better person but in the past 11
years we've been exposed to this new
wave of interpretations where Peter
can't grow up he can't make sacrifices
and he can to be an adult I swear to God
if any of the current writers at Marvel
had a say in this story beyond just
advising Peter would have selfishly
saved not may while the whole city
burned because none of them get it this
Peter Parker is closer to the spider-man
we all grew up on than the one in the
comics recently even though this ending
is just a reverse Last of Us it's still
a very fitting ending and gives me a lot
of hope for where this series can go
assuming they don't make Harry Osborn
become venom that would suck I bet
you're wondering is Xavier just gonna
say ultimate spider-man and web of
shadows are the best because he's a
nostalgia blind no I'm gonna say this is
the best spider-man game because of
ultimate spider-man and web of shadows
and all the others this game didn't do a
single new thing everyone's acting like
they completely reinvented the wheel but
to me it's obvious that this is the
result of a long legacy every piece of
this game rhymes with something we saw
at least once before every good idea was
innovated in a prior game but
re-implemented here it's greater than
the sum of its parts
this game isn't the best because of all
those other games failing to get it
right this game is the best because all
of them did here and there it's a big
collage of everything that worked before
beautifully stitched together into
something that feels new but is actually
quite familiar it's the best Spidey game
because it's every Spidey game so don't
sell any of the classic short and
certainly don't leave them behind
because we wouldn't have this
masterpiece without them it's a
love-letter not only to spider-man but
also to spider-man games both new and
old
truly the bomb squad was the memories we
made along the way it's over I did what
you asked I made the damn video but I
know you're not planning on letting me
go very perceptive mr. Mendoza the Iraq
may feel awkward is finally taken back
what we rode my legacy I just want you
to let you know people are gonna notice
people are gonna notice when I'm gone
mmm
of course while your hoodie wearing
burnout of a brother raised your fridge
I've become more ambitious I've taken
steps to reclaim my birthright no you
don't mean the channel is mine now and I
get to reap the rewards for the work you
did now I don't have to make the
annoying review
you really are renegade but you forgot
one thing don't tie up someone with
masking tape idiot
[Music]
[Music]